en pocos días más comienza una nueva
celebración del mes de la herencia
hispana en quebec alexandra regalado de
qué se trata
buenas noches buenas noches señor les
laborda gracias por la invitación a esta
entrevista como te verán en el 2017 se
depositó un proyecto de ley al gobierno
de quebec para que se declarara en el
mes de octubre como el mes de la
herencia hispana fue justamente en junio
de 2018 que unanimidad el parlamento de
que esté claro a octubre como el mes de
la herencia hispana este es un trabajo
realizado obviamente ideado por mí pero
la madrina de ese proyecto de ley en ese
entonces fue la diputado carol porque en
ese entonces diputada de hoy el haga
mesones
fue gracias a ella y apoyada obviamente
por el diputado de la parte rápida de
saúl polo del partido liberal sea fuerte
el partido que me cuaje y el partido
liberal de québec fue aprobado en
unanimidad me acuerdo que en ese
entonces hablaron hasta en español en el
parlamento porque fuimos invitados
varias personas varios líderes de la
comunidad latinoamericana
entonces en el 2019 ya vimos por ello la
organización herencia hispana quebec
gritad hispanic m en francés y ese es el
objetivo es de continuar la celebración
y la influencia mostrar esa influencia
del rock latino en este país porque
somos una gran cantidad de latinos ya lo
que existimos en todo canadá pero cuando
hablamos de que ve que estamos hablando
más o menos de 135.000 latinoamericanos
y si usted tuviese que describir la
herencia y para en que ve que es de qué
se trata es herencia en que se expresa
es herencia hispana
herencia hispana es una organización sin
fines de lucro que busca promover la
influencia y la presencia
latinoamericana en este lado francófono
de este país desde que realmente
nosotros tenemos la silla no está está
realmente como dicen los franceses está
realmente del lado francés y buscamos
justamente eso
mostrar esa influencia esa presencia
latinoamericana y estimular la economía
de los latinoamericanos en esta en esta
provincia
estamos también en compañía de ana luisa
elgueta
la coordinadora del foro de mujeres de
herencia hispana debe analizar si
tuviéramos que describir la situación de
la mujer en quebec y en qué cambia
respecto a la situación en los países
originarios en américa latina
muy buenas tardes muchas gracias por la
oportunidad de poder presentarnos un
saludo a todos los oyentes
yo llevo muchos años aquí en montreal
y me he dado cuenta que hay muchas
diferencias en todo tipo hay diferencias
culturales diferencias educacionales
diferencias todo en todo tipo de
diferencias pero más que nada es la
oportunidad
y nosotros estamos en este momento
organizando y terminando de organizar ya
que se va a lanzar dentro de unos días
el foro de la mujer hispana
de quebec en montreal es la segunda
edición de este foro y justamente
estamos muy agradecidos de la
cooperación del ministerio de
inmigración y francis acción
nosotros vamos a informar a la mujer
hispana de todas las oportunidades
laborales de todas las oportunidades de
estudio en fin todo lo que se presenta y
todo lo que presenta el gobierno del
quebec y el gobierno federal y que
nosotros desconocemos esa es la
finalidad del foro entonces para
concluir la pregunta que me ha hecho es
simplemente es una diferencia en todo
sentido diferencia cultural diferencia
educacional diferencia en todo sentido
tenemos muchas más oportunidades aquí
que nuestros propios países
alexandra desde cuándo hasta cuándo se
va a celebrar este mes de la herencia
hispana y cuál va a ser la actividad
prevista para esta ocasión sí bueno
nosotros comenzamos el 22 esta semana el
22 de septiembre iniciamos con la
agencia de prensa donde cada año
nosotros anunciamos el país yo no
tenemos cada año país de honor donde
tenemos una estructura totalmente
organizada se coge este año el país del
salvador entonces entre todas las
actividades se le da un protagonismo a
ese país para que puedan desarrollar la
economía justamente de esos ciudadanos y
desarrollar también relaciones entre
canadá quebec montreal y los diferentes
sectores importantes que pueda servir de
desarrollo al país propio después de eso
tenemos el lanzamiento oficial que es el
2 de octubre entre esos nuestros
proyectos principales son como les digo
a todos que tienen que ver con la
economía tenemos el lanzamiento tenemos
el foro de mujeres que son cuatro días
tenemos foros donde jóvenes de origen
latinoamericano que también son cuatro
días tenemos el foro económico que
también son cuatro días tenemos los
miércoles literarios donde tendremos
literatura fantástica de ciencia ficción
aventuras y poesía de latinoamérica
tenemos cuentos y leyendas para los
niños
tenemos el tour gastronómico que
lamentablemente va a ser todo virtual
debido a las circunstancias que estamos
viviendo
pero hemos sido muy proactivo y no
adelantamos aquí lo que pudimos preparar
todo virtual tenemos también una buena
colaboración con naxos en español lo
mejor de nuestra música de eeuu que han
creado toda una programación durante
todo el mes no le damos a disfrutar de
la música clásica vale clásicos de todo
por latinoamericanos pero en el otro
lado para dar esa imagen de talento
tenemos también la música y folklore
latinoamericanos con artistas locales de
acá también vamos a tener
talleres de piñata
y artes visuales con artista totalmente
también local
todo esto lo vamos a hacer virtual en su
en la plasta en la plataforma 'todos a
diferentes horarios entonces tenemos un
total de 125 eventos durante todo un mes
algo muy importante que va a surgir este
año por primera vez es que en la calle
sant josep entre dávinson y no recuerdo
exactamente la calle vamos a tener
banderola que le llaman alquilo oriflama
que son unas banderolas que se utilizan
para promover un festival o un evento y
estas banderolas van a decir feliz
fiesta a osea bomba latinoamericano
américa celebró asamblea de más o menos
el eslogan vuelve el icono americanos y
veremos en conjunto si abrimos juntos
por conjunto eso va a estar desde el
primero hasta el 31 de octubre
vamos a hacer por primera vez entonces
creo que es una iniciativa el primer
gala virtual y obviamente canales
cogemos el orgullo hispano que son de
acuerdo el mismo país de honor se busca
líderes de su propia comunidad que
porque el objetivo es que yo mismo
descubra hacia donde han avanzado
sus hermanos sus gentes y hacen una
búsqueda y tenemos tres orgullo hispano
este año entre ellos un joven que se
llama josé alexandre que participó en la
película lagarde tuvo que adecuar toda
la música que está en esa película está
realmente ella por ese joven que apenas
tiene 22 años los invitamos a que nos
sigan en las redes en facebook en la
página web tenemos mujeres en el foro de
mujeres vamos a tener mujeres importante
como embajadoras entre ellas la de
paraguay a la argentina tenemos también
de la onu de la unesco tenemos mujeres
tenemos acá muchos organismos que están
implicados para ofrecer la información a
las mujeres en cuanto a violencia de
género emprendimiento finanzas cómo
salir adelante durante esta situación de
coronavirus si son empresarias entonces
tenemos bastantes aportes como les digo
más que todo en el enfoque del
desarrollo de los latinos en este país
porque obviamente la música la danza la
gastronomía lo podemos celebrar siempre
entonces el objetivo del mes de la
herencia es el desarrollo económico de
la comunidad latinoamericana
alexandra hotel ha hecho referencia a un
tema que es e insoslayable este año que
es el de la pandemia del coronavirus ha
explicado ya con detalle que buena parte
de la actividad de la celebración del
mes de la herencia hispana este año se
va a ser se va a llevar a cabo perdón
sabe usted también que américa latina es
una de las regiones más castigadas por
la pandemia de el coronavirus entonces
para terminar quería pedirle de parte de
todos los residentes hispanos aquí en
quebec y en canadá un mensaje para los
latinoamericanos en este año en este mes
mejor dicho de herencia hispana pero en
este año marcado a fuego por el
coronavirus cual se que el mensaje que
ustedes podría enviar desde los hispanos
residentes en quebec y canadá realmente
el mensaje que le envió es que los los
hispanos latinoamericanos lo
identificamos por una palabra
perseverancia somos perseverantes somos
luchadores somos una de las comunidades
que más resistimos a los cambios y yo
estoy segura que este año solamente
sería será una transformación positiva
para que nosotros podamos ser en un
futuro una comunidad fuerte y cada vez
más sólida en este país los invito a que
mantengan el ánimo a que continúen
buscando y formándose
y sobre todo protegiendo pse y
protegiendo su familia porque queremos
que todos estén vivo para celebrar y
volvernos a reencontrar el año próximo
dios mediante muy bien
alexandra regalado y ana luisa el geta
del mes de la herencia hispana en quebec
en muchas gracias por esta entrevista
con radio canadá internacional